انضم إلي الآن كاميرون هدسون هو
زميل أول في مركز
الدراسات الاستراتيجية والدولية بمركز
أفريقيا، شكرًا لوجودك معنا، هناك
هذه الادعاءات المستمرة
بارتكاب جرائم حرب في دارفور،
والاغتصاب كسلاح للتطهير العرقي، ما الذي
يواجهه الناس هناك وكيف
من الصعب إيصال المساعدة لهم
بشكل جيد أعني أنهم يواجهون
حرب أهلية شاملة في هذه المرحلة
ميليشيا قوة الدعم السريع مع
الميليشيات العربية الأخرى في المنطقة تهاجم
أه قبائل أقلية دارفورية في المقام الأول
المرسيليت التي نراها  ما يزيد عن خمسة إلى
عشرة آلاف من موس يعبرون
الحدود إلى تشاد كل يوم، لذلك
تظهر مخيمات اللاجئين واسعة النطاق على
جانب الدردشة من الحدود مع عدد
قليل جدًا من الخدمات أو دعم الأمم المتحدة
لاستقبالهم، لذا فهو وضع رهيب بشكل لا يصدق
في اه  West R4 الآن وعندما
تتحدث عن تشاد أعني أن
نائبة الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة أمينة
محمد قالت إنها ذهبت وزارت
اللاجئين في تشاتان وقالت
واقتباسًا منها قالت إنها سمعت
قصصًا عن معاناة لا يمكن تصورها في
السودان ومعاناة هائلة  الاحتياجات في تشاد، كيف
هي الحياة اليومية للأشخاص
الموجودين في مخيمات اللاجئين تلك،
حسنًا، لنتذكر أن العديد من هؤلاء
الأشخاص هذه هي المرة الثانية التي
فروا فيها أه من العنف في دارفور، لذلك نحن
نتحدث عن أشخاص أه بعضهم
ولدوا في معسكرات النزوح أو
اللاجئين في دارفور منذ 20 عاما والآن يهربون من
دارفور مرة أخرى إلى مخيمات النزوح واللاجئين الجديدة
فهي دائرة من
العنف تتكرر أه
لم يكن هناك أبدا محاسبة على
الجرائم التي ارتكبت قبل 15 عاما
أه و  لذلك نحن نرى العديد من
نفس أه الأشخاص يرتكبون الجرائم والعديد
من نفس الضحايا يعانون مرة أخرى
على أيدي قوات الدعم السريع
والميليشيات المتحالفة معها في
دارفور